hi guys so today I'm playing dungeon
nightmares I don't really know too much
about this game pops none it's a horror
game and you guys been asked me to play
more scary games actually did have
someone asked for me to play this game I
know a lot of others YouTube lets
players have been doing this so I
thought I'd jump on the bandwagon I
haven't actually seen any of the videos
yet though so completely new to me I
don't know what's gonna happen
start from scares I think well I hope
yeah let's just say it okay you feel the
darkness surrounding you whenever I
start playing games like this amor is
like should I turn the volume down
okay press C to use she's a mouse for
this try it needs a tracking bad oh gosh
oh oh oh I only had one on that side oh
why isn't it doing that
it's too bad oh I can kind of see it's
fine Oh am I
Oh picking up the gold oh I see oh okay
am I in a real world or is this little
like I think hello
compute world am i ah no she's not play
this game what's over there then steam
oh right a pipe well that would explain
the steam what is this oh I don't like
this oh let's go condo I could use it
what is that buzzing noise is that a
giant bee in here I don't like bees
oh thank you
oh I get none I don't know what I'm
supposed to use two candles should we
just sit down for a moment just chill
out
what is buzzing noise so annoying it's
not supposed to be that hopefully I like
these little dots don't jump out at me
oh god oh god did you hear that did you
hear that I don't even know what the aim
of this game is I should have looked out
really shouldn't I that's just [ __ ]
Jesus
sorry Oh
pipes have I been this way probably what
is that thing why is it following me
what does it want from me I don't know
what is that gentle I I'm lost I can't
see okay I think I've already been this
way sort of stupid I'm just going round
in circles I'm just stupid
oh damn it let's do this way oh why is
that buzzing is so annoying
yasmin I think you were here like a
second ago so annoying oh my god that's
way too quiet from my life
I'm so pleased no I was gonna admit
there oh my god through waiting log ah I
can't play horror games the kids could
see ever why do you think I don't play
them anymore oh there's gonna be
something there but as always is I
haven't been using the candles oh god it
was only a ball of fluff nice jump at
that I don't want to play this anymore
so me why you make me play oh no it's
false chest Oh No death is only the
beginning oh no I just died a second ago
and like still here what am I doing here
nothing jump out at me please
do not enjoy it okay me be brave and use
the candle oh my gosh
what are you okay
that wasn't too bad there's another door
here so why do I like hide like yeah did
they find me quickly with the candles
boys the point of the candles Jesus stop
it stop it because I was doing perfectly
fine without them I'm not perfectly fine
you know I was walking what is that
excuse me I'm confused
it doesn't end because I'm still here it
doesn't make sense if the game had ended
I wouldn't mind I would make my tea and
watch Toy Story and be happy okay I'm
gonna have to explain to my housemates
oh I'm just playing horror game
just sit down it's just a ton of turn
out okay
who has a chest thank you
I have a candle ma'am I kind of run
before I go in here swings make me feel
nice that sound doesn't make me feel
nice so that's what this way I sound
like he came from the other way it's
probably still gonna be something here
that oh geez
it's a big monster in this room but it's
gonna be empty isn't it because that's
what always happens all in horror games
okay and then when I turn around and
come back out something's gonna be there
maybe I don't know no steam yeah I'll
just shut up I don't know anything
so I can hear something like a candle
candle candle Oh what the glitch taken
oh Jesus what's up don't do that to me
wait have I already been here I don't
know don't do the heart beat I hate it
when they do the heart beat
I already been here I've already been
here I'm stupid don't do sounds like
that oh my
in fact what arts fact do I have to play
more I don't want to okay but a try
really bad spiny things though Asuma did
that happen to me in the first time
because if it did that I'm stupid stupid
I should have seen that coming
just stupid oh wow hello
what a nice neck you have okay so this
is different because I don't remember
seeing that weird portrait oh dear
dance and everything is better if you
just dance
steam don't got me no more oh okay stop
it
hey I was just here you won't tilt it
oh wait am i doing go dead person been
dead for decades oh hello Jesus I can't
you just a pair of nope don't
let's talk it
we can't even see I cannot see I just
hear screams I don't even think I don't
even know what you're screaming
did I get it did I get it
did I get that so am I supposed to like
do this seven times when I can't even do
it once because if that is the case then
I'm gonna have to come back to this game
when I'm feeling braver when I have
explained to my housemate so I'm playing
hard I hope you enjoyed this next play
anyway I'm sure you did because the
whole reason is just for you to see
these scared so give this video a thumbs
up if you liked it and if you want to
see me try and finish it which I doubt I
will but who knows maybe one day I'll
just become brave and finish things like
this and have a lovely day or evening I
ah